in 1964 22 year old cassius clay shocked
the world of boxing beating reigning
champion sunny liston to the heavyweight
title muhammad ali as he later became
known wore these gloves in the fight
that brought him worldwide fame
alongside ali's gloves are a pair of
boots worn by brazilian legend pele to
victory at the 1970 world cup final
and michael schumacher's title-winning
car from 2000 in which he ended
ferrari's 21-year wait for the formula
one drivers championship
these are just some of the more than 1
1200 items on display at the 321 qatar
olympic and sports museum
it's due time now for such a museum to
be available in doha you don't have to
search google anymore for you to look
for your favorite sportsman you can
always come into the museum and take a
look get more information i think there
is so much information available in all
sports
it's a building celebrating sporting
history as qatar prepares to make its
own by holding the first world cup in
the middle east
but this museum also looks back on what
this small gulf country has already
achieved
we are a small country but we are strong
in
sport among their most famous sportsmen
rally driver nasa alatia who's won four
dakar rally titles as well as an olympic
medal in shooting
many people ask me
there is another nasser relative in
shooting
to see myself also in the in qatar
museum it's make me younger and i try to
to continue my career
well this museum isn't just dedicated to
historical sporting achievements there's
this whole area that helps encourage
people to be more physically active in
their daily lives and there's all these
games where you can test your speed
strength agility and reflexes like this
one
in which i have to hit as many buttons
as i can
in 30 seconds so let's go
actually these 18 interactive machines
that we have it's a it's a talented
discovery
for the youngest you know for the
children that they could be a future
national team players because they will
score and if they score high points we
will take that statistic hand it to the
federation or to aspire academy so they
can build up a future champion of a
future national team
[Music]
this museum not just showcasing those
who have already made sports history but
taking steps to uncover future stars too
joanna gazroska al jazeera doha